welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Mario Mancuso a senior fellow at the
Jackson Institute for Global Affairs at
Yale mr. Mancuso is a national security
and foreign affairs executive who has
served in a variety of leadership roles
in the United States government
including as Undersecretary of Commerce
for industry and security and deputy
assistant secretary of defense for
Special Operations and combating
terrorism currently he is a corporate
partner and chair of the international
trade and investment practice at freed
Frank Harris Shriver & Jacobson his
particular area of focus is the
relationship between US national
security and globalization at Yale he
teaches a seminar on us strategy and
statecraft in the emerging security
environment and that is what we will
discuss with him today welcome mr.
Mancuso no it's great to be here thank
you for having so you have done so many
things what brings you to Yale first you
know Yale is just an amazing community I
had an opportunity to come to Yale two
years ago President Levin had a
conversation with me and I remember
working with President Levin while I was
still at the Department of Commerce and
you know Yale being a tremendous
learning community premier research
university a focus on really teaching
and really a focus on being engaged in
the world both as a scholarly community
and bringing the world to the campus was
just just an irresistible opportunity
and I'm actually no it's a great
privilege to be here okay so you are
teaching a seminar here for
undergraduates or graduates this
semester's is seniors okay and tell us a
bit about what you're doing with the
students and and how you're bringing
your expertise to the class sure well
this particular semester I'm co-teaching
with sean smith and we're teaching a
course on economic sanctions
and we're actually producing a capstone
project for the Department of the
Treasury we're looking at two sanctions
programs the Libya sanctions programs
and the Burma sanctions program those
were areas rather economic sanctions as
an area of interest for me because I
actually was involved in it when I was
an official in the previous
administration and so during class we
bring to bear the intellects of
tremendous students and seniors but we
also bring to bear what I like to think
is our practical experience in terms of
what policymakers think about when they
think about crafting economic sanctions
programs and so it's a fantastic course
we're really at the end of it now and
the students are producing I think a
great piece of work okay what are some
of the things you think about when you
are crafting economic sanctions well we
think of what the policy objectives are
she's going down to first principles why
would the United States and for what
purpose would it seek to impose an
economic sanctions regime against a
given country and how might a sanctions
regime support that policy objective it
sometimes it simply does it sometimes it
can and sometimes the environment is
such that sanctions well maybe not the
most efficacious policy tool or really
are really the best of the remaining
alternatives okay can you talk about any
of the sanctions you're working on for
Burma or Libya at this point or now we
can talk a little bit about them and I'd
be happy to what the students are doing
is they're looking at these sanctions
programs these are very different
sanctions programs and looking at them
in comparative perspective what were a
what were their policy objectives and
they're slightly different in both cases
did they work and if they did why if
they didn't to the extent they didn't
why didn't they work and in a couple of
surprising conclusions come about I
don't want to steal their thunder so i
won't go into all of them but
effectively i think i think the students
have come to a position and realizing
that when policymakers think about
economic sanctions they just simply
can't assume the primacy of the american
economic system in the international
system that tools are both more
difficult than more possible for
policymakers and they have to think in a
nuanced way as to what their objective
and whether or not a particular
sanctions programs will work it used to
be I think somewhat reflexive for us
policymakers to think that sanctions
could be the the you know the sort of
the magic bullet and that's clearly not
the case but of course sanctions can be
helpful and I think history teaches us
that when applied thoughtfully they can
be helpful in achieving policy
objectives can you speak to anything
from your background in terms of an
example of that I actually think I
actually think the Burma sanctions
programs the US sanctions program has
been at least thus for I believe
moderately successful now there's some
academic debate about whether that's
true and I think that's I mean they're
you know differing views on that but i
think it's undeniable that Burma's
relatively recent political opening has
had something to do with us sanctions
now whether it that had more to do with
it whether sanctions had more to do with
it then Burma's own economic
mismanagement I think that's an open
question I think that's essentially
unknowable but I think I think at least
to me without us pressure I think Burma
would be in a very different place today
and so I think I think US policy over
the course of a number of
administrations it's been clumsy at
times I think it's gotten better and I
think President Obama and his
administration should be commended for a
pretty differentiated approach with the
regime I think it's I think it's been
about as successful as a sanctions
program can be mm-hmm the end of the day
these are pretty blunt instruments but I
think that's a good case okay let's talk
about your background a little bit you
spent some time in the military and of
course the government let's talk about G
expertise you're bringing to the
classroom you know I I tend not to
emphasize expertise because in a place
like Yale it's always a dangerous thing
to do but i do think i'd bring some
unique experience life and i was a
military officer i was ROTC i served in
the military left the military stayed in
the reserves went to law school and then
had an opportunity
to serve in appointed government
positions where I brought to bear my own
experience as an officer and and and a
real interest and passion for national
security and international affairs with
my experience in the private sector that
culminated in that I think with a number
of different positions in the second
term of president george w bush's
administration so i served from 2005 to
2009 in a number of different roles and
you know it was a remarkable time and i
think some of the themes that became
emergent then IE this nexus between
globalization and national security how
has the u.s. security profile changed
what constraints this does u.s.
statecraft have what opportunities does
u.s. statecraft have in light of all of
these changes so what credit is feeling
what are some of the opportunities i
think i think some of the opportunities
are frankly it forces us i mean the
world looks very different I mean this
is cliche by now but 20 years ago the
world was a different place the US was I
think universally hailed as a single
superpower and I think we had assumed
that we could we the United States could
do what it wanted on the international
scene I effectively clearly that's not
true today and I think a good example of
that is for example the asia-pacific
region i mean the united states is still
the world's only effectively superpower
there is at least one near pier
competitor but if you were to just take
out the pacific and look at it it's
probably the only part of the world that
i think today is effectively multipolar
not a military sense there the United
States as singular advantages but an
economic sense in a cultural sense where
the u.s. really has to in many respects
struggle to maintain vibrant
relationships with us with its allies to
maintain healthy and constructive
relationships with the Chinese and I
think what what the changes is forced us
to do is frankly to be better to be more
nuanced in how we think about the u.s.
conducts diplomacy how it conducts
international affairs how it maintains
relationships for a long time it was
enough to have a highly developed
military instrument of state power
in terrific diplomats but now we're
forced to basically have everything in
between we're forced to have those two
bookends but we're forced to develop
tools everywhere in between those and by
the way sanctions is a tool that Falls
neatly between those two bookends and so
thinking about a new taxonomy for
statecraft I think globalization has
forced us to do that and we're still
learning there is so much going on in
the world now and I'm wondering what
your thoughts are in terms of the
greatest challenges you know we have the
conflict in Syria going on for instance
the Middle East issues you know how in
teaching the students to work on these
problems what are some of the the things
that you talked about you know it's
interesting I think there frankly the
world is filled with problems so there's
a lot to talk yes I don't know if them
if this sort of the bright shiny objects
of the news are the most important us
challenges speaking as a former US
policymakers they're very important we
should care about them we should be
attuned to them but we can easily
confuse what's loudest with what's most
important what's most important I think
probably the thing that we we need to
really think about is our role in the
Pacific Pacific and how do we Midwife a
truly constructive and balanced
relationship with China that is
critically important in my view a
near-term problem that we need to
address is the problem of Iran I think
what is now I think the Arab winter but
what was once the Arab Spring that's a
concern for the United States and our
role in the region and the importance of
that region is something we should be
mindful of but i think the the probably
the most important long-term challenge
is how to have a constructive role with
China and finding our way there is I
think what should really keep us up do
you have any thoughts on that no no
thoughts no I I think
I think I think one of the striking
things about China and one of the
striking things about the us-china
relationship that is unlike any other
superpower relationship that we've had
in our past is the following during the
Cold War the Soviet Union was clearly a
military competitor but it was never
really an economic competitor in the 80s
Japan was an economic competitor but it
was not a military competitor in fact it
was an ally China is both at the same
time an economic Challenger and a
strategic competitor and so that has in
many respects flummoxed US policymakers
but it's it's our urgent task it's a
critical relationship it will it will
shape the international system for a
long time and now that China has a new
leader do you think things will possibly
improve with China get a little easier
or perhaps more difficult or is it too
early to tell yeah I think times have
change are always times of danger and
great opportunity I do think it's
incumbent and times of transition to
seize the momentum and to try to
establish good practices early for that
I think the United States should really
focus on asia president obama has
announced a pivot we are positioning
more forces that relatively modest a
number but but quite apart from our
military footprint which is in my view
not the most important piece to this
puzzle in asia at least is our economic
relationships are we speaking of our
allies in the region are we engaged in a
thoughtful way if we were to open up the
sort of US government's Outlook calendar
where are we spending our time the you
know does the time we spend and where we
spend that time does it match up with
what we think our strategic priorities
are I think Asia is a strategic priority
right and what about your policy
interests let's talk about that a little
bit this China play into that it does it
does principally both military and
economics and trade
and how in my private sector role it
also comes up you know Chinese
investment in the United States how does
the US government view that how does the
US government regulate that for national
security purposes one of my roles when I
was at commerce was to participate on
what's called the Sophia's committee the
committee on foreign investment United
States which has been in the news of
light which is the US government's body
that reviews foreign direct investment
when there's a national security overlay
to it that's critical and so with
respect to China how various economic
issues whether it's the currency whether
its foreign direct investment whether
its technology trade how those both you
know how they reveal national security
stresses in the relationship I'm
fascinated by that I think it's
important and that's what I that's what
I'm involved in does China own a good
portion of the United States as the
rumor has it I know Hawaii's our great
concern you know it is first it's you
know China is invested in the United
States China is invested in in different
parts of the world and let's not forget
it's actually affirmative US policy to
encourage foreign direct investment we
need foreign direct investment our
savings rate hasn't been as high as it
it historically has been we needed for
economic purposes the question is is how
do we get the benefits of foreign direct
investment with mitigating any national
security downsides I think the u.s. is
is like other countries by the way
struggling with how to sovereign
investors how do not private investors
but how do investors who are affiliated
with a government a country how do they
make investment decisions are they
making investment decisions on purely
economic spaces which of course should
not be problematic because economics is
not zero sum on the other hand is there
a strategic intent behind those
investments that might be inconsistent
with security interests and that's a
hard you know we need to develop a finer
sift and government for figuring out
which transactions are problematic and
which are not I was going to ask you
that how do you tracked that well you
know
the Committee on Foreign Investment
actually is a process and it's mostly
transaction focused in on any given
transaction I think it's fairly
straightforward the intelligence
community plays an important role and
there are a number of policy interests
for example if a given transaction you
know raises the prospect of sensitive us
technology going to a foreign acquire
well that's could be problematic if a
given transaction threatens to interrupt
the supply of a critical good that a US
business that is the subject of the
transaction supplies to the US
government that would be an area where
the US would be concerned about and
similarly if a trent if a given
transaction could be the basis for a
means of intrusion into the united
states through networks for example that
would also be in a basis but those are
micro factors but in many respects
defining risk in that setting is i think
the bigger challenge because it depends
on what you mean by risk is it
transaction risk ie what I've just
described to you or is it systemic risk
the systemic risk the larger risk is
what happens if you have a restrictive
investment regime that discourages
foreign investment United States and
that investment goes goes to places in
the world outside the United States
places including that might become
strategic competitors to the United
States and so it's how you define the
risks which risks are most important how
do you mitigate them and you can't do
everything everywhere all the time but i
think the the u.s. process is currently
focused on the transaction risk and I
think it has done that fairly well at
least in the last two or three years and
I think it will get better at doing that
okay but it's been clumsy in the past at
times well if there was one thing you
would like your students to take away
from your class what would it be you
know I'd love for them to continue to be
just engaged in learning about the world
the world is an amazing place and being
at a place like Yale gives you
tremendous opportunities and and to take
full advantage of that and to be
thoughtful to be in
alektra assertive and to really try to
make a difference I mean I would want
them to always to remember the class as
a class that that made them care made
them think and made them more and more
engaged very good thank you so much for
being here with us today oh it's my
pleasure thank you for more information
about mr. Mancuso please visit our
website at yale edu slash mcmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale